movie studios had a history with comic
book movies by the year 2000
unfortunately with a few exceptions that
wasn't a very good history the pattern
for super heroic films over the last
five decades had been a cycle of
originality followed by shoddy imitators
and sequels followed by a break followed
by the whole thing starting over again
things changed in 2000 with the release
of x-men 2 both critical acclaim and
commercial success closed on his heels
came Sam Raimi's spider-man in 2002
which was the third highest-grossing
film of the year and sent Hollywood
scrambling to adapt every comic property
they could get their hands on 2003 's x2
and 2004 spider-man to up the ante
critically beloved in commercial
blockbusters these two set the bar for
the first five years of the new
millennium after half a decade of fun
flashy comic bear and also the movie
Catwoman the industry got a shock in
2005 with the release of Batman Begins
followed in the same year by V for
Vendetta
and since it gritty realism adult themes
and no more spandex in primary colors
Batman Begins set a new standard for
everything that followed it if that
didn't cement it enough the critical
battering that Bryan Singer's Superman
Returns to the following year confirmed
that audiences didn't want to throw back
to a more innocent age the darkness of
high grossing superhero Pictures
affected non comic movies as well from
Star Trek to Skyfall blockbusters have
spent a decade imitating the trends that
started in this genre the next
game-changer was in 2008 when the Dark
Knight earned half a billion dollars
domestically making it the highest
grossing film of the year and raised the
standards for all superhero movies Heath
Ledger's terrifying performances the
Joker earned him a posthumous Oscar and
helps make the film an inescapable
phenomenon that summer this was the
height of the dark superhero grip no
other film ever did serious as well but
it didn't stop them from trying the
second-place film of 2008 seemed like a
long shot starring an actor who spent
some time out of the limelight in recent
years and directed by the man who had
most recently made satura Iron Man
defied expectations and delivered an
incredible blend of smart funny and
exciting that would come to define the
Marvel Cinematic Universe that followed
it there was another 2008 entry in
Marvel's movie
the world the Incredible Hulk but rather
than the fun of Ironman it honed closer
to the scowly seriousness that dominated
comic movies at the time and is pretty
much forgotten subsequent marvel
pictures have all been fashioned roughly
in the ironman model while warner
brothers and DC collaborations have all
had a certain dark and gritty streak
even extending it to everybody's
favorite Big Blue Boy Scout Superman in
2013 it's arguable that nothing's had
the same impact on the world of comic
movies subsequent to the launch of the
Marvel Series in the six years since
it's become seemingly a requirement to
have every movie of Studio makes be an
entry into a larger world with expanded
plots and characters shared across film
DC Warner Brothers and Fox and Stoney
owned Marvel titles have all attempted
to bottle the same magic that Disney
owned Marvel perfected with 2012's
Avengers which significantly beat The
Dark Knight Rises that is seemingly
proving the shift away from standalone
films but why have we seen a solid
decade and a half of uninterrupted super
heroics on the big screen the credit is
probably due in part to the technical
breakthroughs that have allowed these
movies to be as visually rich and
believably fantastic as they're drawn
comic counterparts in addition the
business has changed since the comic
bubbles of the 80s and 90s giant media
corporations now approach every movie as
a franchise look for stories that come
pre-loaded with proven super fans and
own both movie studios and the
publishing companies that produce cons
with Disney and Marvel planning a
rollout of films through at least 2021
and Warner Brothers Fox and Sony all
slating superhero films well into the
next decade this kind of movie shows no
sign of slowing down so get used to the
masks and capes it's been a long road
but it looks like they're here to stay
what's your favorite comic movie which
comics would you like to see in movie
form comment below and let us know how
you feel